I want to let you know that I have some
new tour dates to announce
Charlottesville VA on February
one uh Raleigh North Carolina February 2
Colombia South Carolina February 3 and
Knoxville Tennessee Go Big Orange on
February 4 at the Knoxville Coliseum as
well State College PA on February 7th
Syracuse New York February 8 and M Hurst
Massachusetts on February 9th get your
tickets early starting Wednesday
November 29th at 10:00 a.m. local time
with code Rat King General on sale
starts Friday December 1 at 10:00 a.m.
local time all tickets available at
theo.
comom um don't buy through secondary
sites if the prices are jacked up just
wait we'll come on back through town but
uh looking forward to bringing the tour
near you thank you for the support
today's guest has a new comedy special
coming out on Netflix on December 5th uh
he's The Pride of Baltimore and one of
the most entertaining men young men in
the universe uh today's guest is Mr
stavos
Halas shine that light on
me
I'll sit and tell you my
stories
sh and I will find a song I will
[Applause]
sing I knew an Albanian girl we yeah she
got her I remember she got her belly
button
braided sorry I love it we're good she
was the only girl that had cornrow
outside of her belly button oh yeah a
Fierce People not not saying anything
about your wife my friend but my
producer Albanian also really yeah eldis
my boy big dumb blockheaded Albanian
piece of and so what is because we
just referenced guys uh stavos huses
here today up Bros uh we're GNA talk
about his new special and uh that's
coming out on Netflix when is it uh
December 5th fat Rascal mhm next week
bro that's right dud thank you thank you
wow this your first one on there first
one on there I had the I did my own on
YouTube yep and then I've just been
putting out a bunch of on on
YouTube and you know social media and
so yeah we we put it out there
there's something that well two things
first of all we talked about the
producer today Alex logos is in and he
married an Albanian yes that's right he
did which you know sleep with one eye
open that's what I would say don't leave
any live stock on attended she might
abscond with your
goats why is that dude they just have
like a hankering for Animals dude so ALB
so in Greece albanians are like it it's
B borders Greece right my so my best
friend growing up Albanian and but like
the the relationship of like Albania and
Greece is like what you might say like
Mexico is to America where it's like
there's a lot of illegal immigrants that
like will take any job just to be in the
country that shows you how shitty
Albania is like Greece's economy is what
they want to get get in on you know what
I mean G just went bankrupt a years ago
yeah yeah but like literally and my
family's from Athens so it's like you
you know you know we're high
class dude you know what I mean we're
like we're like we got the parthan on
right there but I went to
visit you know I went to visit we got it
right there that's right you can see it
bro I went to visit my uh uh my my my
friend from Baltimore our families were
in Greece at the same time and we drove
to his like hillbilly ass hick like
Village and in Alan in right like
northern Greece closer to Albania these
like still had an ouse
they had indoor plumbing but they just
had it For the Love of the Game just to
also out about Outdoors
really you know what I'm saying it
connects you to Mother Gaia oh yeah it's
like take that
government you know I don't need the
Department of Sanitation telling
me where to that's one vote for
Trump right there dude every time he
in the yard homie absolutely uh
that's how that's how they're taking the
census they're count how many turds are
in underneath under people's
yards um but we went to his
Village and they straight up had this
was the year this must have been
2002 they had an Albanian indentured
servant I'm not even kidding they had
this that like wasn't
allowed upstairs had his own little
basement apartment and they were
like yeah we couldn't the last Albanian
took our shoes so we couldn't trust him
in the in the main house anymore
and I was like what the is going on
I'm coming from Baltimore and I'm like
they have light Albanian slavery in
these in these Villages dude
this was 2000 post 911 it was crazy and
you can vot right now on slavery right
now on the uh on the YouTube uh no I
look man I think yeah if I the first
time you see uh shoes that's
yeah laces you're like damn look
at these body
tires
help so yeah I guess albanians and do
they have is there a mental issue with
them because really I would no I think I
think you you know um my I think that's
what they would this guy this particular
guy I don't remember his name 100% had a
bit of a mental issue oh yeah big Smiler
let's say yeah yeah my boy had big
Smiler not the best teeth that did not
slow him down for one second you know
what I'm saying but oh dude no windows
but still cutting the lights on
absolutely kind of skip doesn't skip a
beat like they're just hurling you know
uh insults at him and he's just taking
it with a grin and getting some fresh
well water for for supper you know what
I mean doesn't bother him at all heavy
pet dude oh yeah kind of dude that'll
just stir thing of hot soup with his
hand
absolutely those those nerves have
been dead for years those nerves have
been dead after multiple like raccoon
bites those that thumb is dead dude
let's just say hip hop herab dog okay
yeah they should study him dude yeah how
he survived they should study him it
would take about 40 minutes yeah
absolutely yeah if you go well it would
be one there's one extra something
there's anra that would take a little
longer but dude that extra chromosome
there's also it must have creatine in it
because a lot of people that are you
know men you know a lot of people call
them menal or uh you know uh people that
are missing in action but aren't missing
you sure sure sure sure sure sure they
those people they're absolutely the uh
the torque that's in them mhm well yeah
they're literally more they're one extra
amount dude so they are stronger they're
hyper masculine that's that extra
chromosome is that true absolutely yeah
so the extra chromosome at least that's
one type one style okay I don't know if
it's we're talking Downs right now I
believe I had a friend who whose son had
the extra and I think the extra X is
girls Y is dudes I believe so if you're
x y y that means you're like a turbo bro
yeah so those hairy you
know eyebrows wild jacked jacking off
fast you know at a young age like oh
they can jack off and then catch it on
their
eyebrows you know absolutely in for like
we're talking like yeah it's like
hanging up the Christmas lights oh damn
look what Randy an
icicle yeah yeah yeah
B dude we had yeah we had uh uh Uncle he
used to masturba in his sleep right he
had um I think he had an iron deficiency
or something um so that whenever he
stayed over my mom get more of these
Jingle Bells on his
wrists ironically the more they jingle
little iron probably peeled off went
into his bloodstream his hand full of
iron puts it on his open and he
gets into his bloodstream it's a
win-win yeah I think she just wanted to
keep things you know if he started
cleaning himself out she she wanted to
keep things Co course it's it's a good
safety mechanism too but I'm just saying
the Silver Lining he might be up you
know he might have more energy
throughout the day cuz his higher levels
are regulated well I think he was
missing some silver lining which problem
at the beginning but yeah he was copper
heavy dude you can see some of those
dudes we had a guy in our neighborhood
had he was had extra copper in
his blood or whatever and he if he would
have to he had real heavy eyelids so
when they blink down his whole head
would kind of go down like that like it
just that's tough you know and then he
had a C1 cervical ISS he had I think
some kind of spinal issue because of the
sure the constant heavy heavy blinking
that copper baby that's gonna take a
toll on the neck either it's going to
get stronger or you're and he
just didn't have it in him he didn't
have that thick neck yeah he didn't have
that torque in him but yeah
congratulations Alex too Alex just and
he knocked up the lady the we got a we
got a half on
Deck alert alert the learnt the
maternity
ward he got a with some slippery
fingers yeah just say hey he's going to
take the other baby's pacifiers out of
the hey hide the fent inol
patches you know what I'm saying we got
an
Albanian dude that would be the best
cartoon if you ever did a carto it would
just be Albanian babies absolutely AB
Albanian babies yeah what do you say
guys huh well in the Bronx they're like
that's the mafia like albanians well
yeah babies yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm sure
there's some tough ALB babies yeah
albanians I love there's something about
that Russian like um you know you'll get
your child like a a doll made out of
stone you know your child like a 30 lb
doll yes like a yes absolutely a real
life Gollum you get them a real Jewish
folklore they're like look we're going
to have to train against these because
they tend to also be anti-semitic and
they think Golems are real so they get
their baby oh yeah are they really an
well I think a lot of the the Eastern
Eastern world is really well because you
got to look at Europe they figure ways
to be racist like Yugoslavia broke up
because Serbia thinks they're different
from Croatia or whatever right
to like you wouldn't know the
difference right I I barely would so is
it indiv is it or is it that they also
respect their individuality more I'm not
think is that is that part of it too
that like because are they anti
everything are they anti like yes they
definitely think they're the the man
right every like they think like each
little fu Village it goes back to like
Village so it's like but that but
it's so funny to be like you'll see
people who will kill you know
grandmothers over this conflict and then
you like zoom out and it's like same
guy you know what I mean like
there's nothing different it's like the
tracksuits are slightly different colors
you know what I mean but they're the
same type of they're you know same dude
uh but it is funny to have like there's
everyone has pride in that part of the
world everybody has Pride then it's like
you can drive through the country like
you can drive through Greece in eight
hours it's not a big country but
like yeah dude it's crazy when you go
through a trip to Europe and you're like
the French and the English just for
thousands of years fought each other and
they're you know a 20 minute
helicopter ride apart you know what I
mean like it's it's like getting the
Queens from Queens to JFK it's like you
that's part of France is that close to
England it's up dude that's why
yeah it is crazy to think I wish
sometimes I wish we still I wish we had
more stuff like that I wish we would
sometimes go to state governments do you
think we would that we could end up like
that over here get go more individual
State statewise like you know the
original sort of conception where
everybody has their own little their own
little Vibe yeah I think it would just
be I mean it would make Sports would be
so much more exciting because you would
be like if yeah if Georgia is playing
California they are playing California
yeah yeah well that that is what's cool
about like I love soccer obviously and
that's the one thing American Sports
misses is that like these are countries
that literally fought each other like
when you have Algeria playing
France those colonized
Algeria like Algeria wants to them
up so it is cool but yes I think you're
right it would be a real there'd be a
real melee situation I think about that
sometimes where it's like yeah what does
happen if we just you know everyone
everyone calls each other's Bluff and
we're just like you you we're
separate countries and then we see what
happens yeah I think I think it would be
really exciting and I think well it
would definitely be more exciting and
also the states are getting really
different you're having states that are
like going bankrupt you're having states
that are keeping it together you have
states that are like um you know that
can't take care of their people you have
states that that can take care of their
people you know um you have states that
have like legal gun carry and states
that you know it's like I think you're
getting they seem to be getting more
separate than together and I think we as
a country seem to be getting like that
at times yeah I mean it's also
huge you do think about it you're like
this really shouldn't be one country we
really should break it up you know a
couple countries yeah give a couple
countries you know still no pass still
like like the EU I can go vacation there
you know what I mean I don't want to
have to do a bunch more paperwork to get
in right but you know that's the other
thing you know the culture War
would get so annoying where it would be
like if you're from New York and you
just want to come hang out in the South
you know they would they would
with you a little more and vice
versa you know what I mean they would be
like Yankees yeah yeah yeah absolutely
you have you'd have to wear like a gay
patch yeah you know if you went to if
you were gay you mean yeah yeah yeah oh
to let like a star David thing or
whatever you have there' be certain
places where it's like if you're trans
we want to know yeah put a patch on
we're put the trans P got problem we
just want to know what we're dealing
with coming to Florida yeah look it's
it's hunting season just started and
some of these guys can't see well so we
W yeah put patch on look if you have uh
if you're sexually uncertain we need you
to put this orange vest on yeah exactly
yeah because we want to know if we
you if it's gay or not that's it nothing
to do with you it's all about our
accounting we keep track of our own
you're on vacation we're not going to
with you but if you get sucked off
by our pal he gets one gay strike and
then he can't yeah three strikes and
you're
out three strikes they take a little bit
of your penis away unless you get
elected as to be a senator you get two
more strikes yeah that would yeah that
would be yeah that's interesting it
would make making uh state government
even gayer which is hard to do dude I
just put I I think I would it would be
neat there would be
more like excitement about your state I
think or you would have to take more
State responsibility yeah I think um
what was some would be some of the the
good points of that I wonder well I
think a lot of it would be you would get
to decide how to spend the money I worry
that I think it's a good idea in theory
and again I don't know because
it's been so long since I've actually
known like this but I think a lot
of states depend on federal funding way
more than we realize yeah just say
Mississippi if you want to right right
right right right I think what would
happen is like uh um and and also it's
like once you stop being different once
you stop being like you could in theory
be like well we're not going to spend
money on the military like there could
be like you know liberal states are like
we're putting our money into whatever
the and then it's like first of all
who gets all the who gets all the B all
the planes that's would we play
like rock paper scissors for that
well the military would still have to be
a general consensus unless you'd have
state military as well right but you
would you what you're talking about
essentially is becoming independent
countries basically or coalitions you
know what I mean like if you broke it up
into four states maybe divided up by
population yeah maybe it would be yeah
it would definitely be exciting bro to
have that going on in our lifetime like
whoa we started out as a country we
couldn't do it couldn't do it and so we
started to separate why wouldn't you
up the like the liberal C the
liberal country though like it just
feels like it would be a quick like all
the place with guns if I were a gun guy
yeah and we and you gave if you took you
know New York and La these huge
economies it's like why don't we just go
kill those guys like it would be
why would you just declare war and be
like dibs on you know this yeah oh
I think at definitely at New Year's Eve
when it was like the time where you
shoot guns in the air I have a feeling
everybody would just turn their guns
right over to the state they don't love
yeah yeah absolutely so the bullets all
flew over there got well who knows who
knows where it comes down not not my
problem I'm
celebrating you're just unloading the
clip or an Albanian wedding maybe let
the clip let the clip sing Let
The Chopper sing for an Albanian
wedding oh dude that's fun man I would
live where would you I would have to
stay I would have to stay in the
whatever
Northeast uh country would be i' would
be a New York guy I think so you would
yeah I think you would be a BAL as long
as Baltimore of Baltimore yeah yeah yeah
I would hope Baltimore and New York
would be in one kind of Mid Atlantic I
think that's what would happen you'd
have kind of like a you know what I mean
you'd have clumps it wouldn't be just 50
it wouldn't be 50 countries what we're
talking about here oh you say we
probably get down about maybe 20 States
or something 20 maybe 10 you know what
I'm saying maybe five who
knows what if it was some weird
state that formed all across the like
Georgia
fornia and it was like this they just
took or just yeah took all the coastline
they're like we're the Beach State suck
my dick you want to come to a beach you
got to you got to go through me
that would be dude if
San Francisco like commandeered like all
like certain like like all the they
owned all the like certain rest areas
along the way yeah yeah yeah well that's
what you do with the homeless put them
to work give them a couple guns give
them you know what I mean like you would
have you would have the you you could
have the homeless Marine Corps you know
what I mean where it's like they just
got needles you know they got little
Wolverine hand needles coming at you you
know what I mean that's oh or they're
all they have like a big needle yeah
yeah one giant needle and they just load
it up and just yeah and then they just
run and inject it into somebody yeah
yeah yeah is it Fenty is it hormones who
knows yeah dude I got Nan you're just
hitting each other with different
needles that is interesting cuz my my
gut reaction would be well Whoever has
guns you know Southern States whatever
would it up but every every time I
feel like you look at Fox News it's like
a different guy that's so scared to go
to New York City who's like the toughest
guy it's like you have guns and but
you're scared of the homeless so it's
kind of a natural it would it would be a
natural like stalemate where it's like
we would just need a wall of patrolling
and then give them houses give them
little sick homeless Huts lean toos on
the outside absolutely get a shanty town
teach farming to homeless people I
wonder if well I think yeah one of the
big issues with the homeless is just
that it's uh there's two there's like
half people are not doing well half the
people are drug users there's huge beef
on the street between homeless and just
drugs on the drugs sleeping Outdoors
doing drugs right right right yeah we
don't know about that c get out of our
community kind of thing right there's a
yeah there's a lot of beef out there
between those two cultures I get that
dude they I talked about this before I
think but they had in Los Angeles my
apartment is right by a big park right
and it's hella homeless out there
there's a dude that they caught killing
uh he had a rooster and then they
finally found the dude that had it right
it was waking everybody up right for a
four block radius this thing
they finally no chicken's just the
rooster well he ended up kill killing
the bird and and doing a meal with it oh
nice and then they had another pair of
guys and one of them I think was a woman
but whatever sure sure everybody can do
what they want yep and uh but yeah they
were two men and
then they they stole a bunch of high
school band equipment
right so bro it was that's awesome
crazy if you're GNA do homeless crime
make it fun you know what I
mean with your dick hanging out of your
old ass
[Music]
sweatpants Benny and the Jets they were
just bro they hit his head sheet music
from a high
school awesome oh God it was
you got a lot of time you got a
lot of time on your hands if your
homeless Master an instrument oh yeah
that's you know what I'm saying like you
know I mean like let's learn how to play
the French horn dude the
that's nice yeah
there's some guy playing Taps every
night when they go to
bed I love that dude that's sick
yeah man um but dude congratulations
there is something that or I don't know
if you feel it because you're from a
little bit younger generation than me
right or you know probably 10 years
younger so do you feel like was there a
level of getting Netflix that made you
it made you feel a certain way because
mean for sure was there yeah yeah I mean
I think I think part of it was like
these last couple years went better than
I thought possible you know what I mean
like I put out the special and I started
posting clips and people just responded
in a way that I'm still confused a
little bit about where I'm like or these
like theaters and like that and
part of me was like this is sick
I'll always continue to do this I love
having control over how like people
interact with my but at the end of
the day there is something there's a
huge a totally different type of
audience on Netflix mainstream people
that really even though everything's
moving online that's like moves
slower than people give it credit for
right so there's still so many people
that like don't know who the you
are if you're just on YouTube even
though it might even though it really
helps selling tickets so it was like I
was just like I want one like I have no
mainstream credits I have not one like
you know no late night no you
know no TV none of that so it was
just like let's get one real one and
let's let it be a place where
everybody it still has that like
like there because there's no Comedy
Central hour anymore there's no HBO
special anymore I mean I know they exist
don't get me wrong but it's like Netflix
for a while I think became the the place
for comedy and so and I think they kind
of they realize that with everybody
doing YouTube like everybody who got
specials recently you know you look at
Shane you know what I mean like Sam Mark
SCH whatever everybody me we all had to
go do it we had to almost prove
it and then Netflix like oh this
this is going yeah like but then they're
doing a good job of like they're like no
do it here now and I think it's been a
really good thing of for comedy where
it's like we all made our own fan bases
and now it's like now some of us are
bringing fan bases there but then it's
like there's regular that
just want to watch you know I mean the
office is on peacock now but like the
office just some mainstream that
have no clue who I am so it was
hu it was it does feel really cool and a
lot of PE it's funny cuz people in your
audience will be like dude Netflix hell
yeah that's huge and it's like it is but
also like you're here you know what I
mean like you found me already why does
it matter that I got NE but like it does
still matter and to me it feels cool
because it's like you know it feels like
the place
where theoretically it could be some
huge not that I'm banking on to be some
huge hit but it's like you're at least
in the mix where it's like all the
mainstream is on there so it's like
you're at least you feel like you're in
a different you know kind of in a little
bit of a different like League a little
bit Yeah so it was cool no it's
interesting yeah cuz I think it used to
feel like yeah if you got a special on
something or or you got it wasn't you
couldn't tell your friends you were a
comedian it felt like right this is just
my perception that until you got
something on television you know or
something you know something on
streaming something somewhere until then
a lot of people thought you were just
like a gay guy like trying not to be gay
you know like damn like dude absolutely
this guy this how out of his system yeah
you know he can't sing he can't dance
all he's got is telling little stories
he tried playing the homeless trombone
he got blown off the streets so
now he's got to do his gay little
stories yeah that was it it really is
art for the least talented people in the
world that's what we're doing it's like
we have no we are not showman you put us
in the 20s when everyone every how you
doing my lady you know in between they
had to be their own dance guys we're
we just kind of tell
humorous
stories yeah we would be on a wanted
poster oh my god dude we were peeping
times before they had Windows yeah dude
yes absolutely just be just trying to
put your cheek up against the woman's
window and maybe her she rubbed her tits
on it for a second some of that heat
gets through that window God I miss all
that and I love
[Music]
that you know
uh yeah but there was there there was
something about getting it in a place
and I think having it a place where it's
like I think it starts to if there's any
I was just wondering there used to be
this thing in our heads that would be
like oh man this thing's spinning and if
I don't get once you get something in a
place where people can go view it then
it feels like you're at least a you've
achieved some goal totally if even know
if it's a success but it's a goal it no
I really feel that way a little bit
where it's like so that's what I was
wondering is it still like that it feels
like a like a safe point in a
video game right you know what I mean we
can save it now yeah yeah yeah it's like
I can take a break cuz dude I've been
I've been going like I've been
not since the pandemic ended it's like
it literally has just been like my road
business and my like on mine has
kept growing to a point where I felt
like I couldn't stop I was like I needed
some tangible thing even though that's a
little in your head I think we're both
and a lot of people are just a little
neurotic in comedy where you have to
feel like you have earned a break and to
me it does this thing does feel that way
where it's like I worked hard as
put out a special busted my ass to get
more material in a year so that I could
potentially do this and now it's like we
saved I'm going to go I'm going to
do some side quests you know I'm inv
viice City I'm gonna go I'm gonna go you
know to the do the cheat the hack where
they suck you off yeah you know what I
mean I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to the
beach and shoot you know what I mean
just like hang out like I can't wait to
do that but yeah it definitely feels
that way and it's hard because not a lot
there's not a lot of that stuff anymore
a little bit of it feels like we we
don't know a path there are no answers
wow the thing that's except maybe your
own podcast which is kind of why I
started one too where it was just like
that's like you're connected to your
people once a week and I love that
aspect of it but everything else dude
YouTube YouTube could decide we
don't want dirty on our platform
tomorrow and then what the do you
do you're you know and it's like
even you know Instagram Tik Tok all
those can change their
algorithm like that they could ban you
just I got plenty of you know what
I mean we plenty of PE all comed said
some wild banable if they decide to
switch up so it's like so it does you
but this does feel like hey I have this
body of work at least where it's like
the big picture thing that's there and
then it'll help with all this other
until we figure out what the next thing
is yeah yeah it's cool man well
congratulations dude thanks dud you
really deserve it and yes but it was
cool I know you and I cross pass a
couple weeks ago yeah yeah we were both
in Cleveland in Cleveland yeah dude that
was cool man that was awesome that was
sick that was cool man Aran the
the house of you were playing akan where
LeBron LeBron was built yeah the darkest
theater I'd ever been in very dark I had
no idea how gigantic it was I literally
thought I was like oh cool Theo's doing
like he wants to do some small theaters
and I thought it was like people
right in front of us and then they
turned the lights on and this
goes up like that high
there was like suicide section huh oh we
do five or six guys dive off
there bung jump off that yeah a
couple dudes that yeah some auditioning
for antifa had my shows whatever um yeah
dude it's crazy we had a show last night
I am tired man we had a show last night
in uh Huntsville hell yeah what was I
thinking about oh when you said Federal
funding oh so if say if they did divide
into States right so Louisiana there was
a time where they were given Federal
funding and they said we had to change
our drinking law from 18 to 21 can you
pull that up Alex what that's
and we said
you bro we said you not only are we
going to be drunk but we're going to let
our roads deteriorate so we drive yeah y
the following year there was like 7,000
drunk driving
desk like we try us
we don't care they're like it's babies
with fetal alcohol syndrome
driving yeah it's Albanian babies pull
up an article just if you see something
like that that's awesome dude
yeah I respect that so much but we tried
I remember
to do that and for a few years it stood
up and everybody's excited we can drink
you know but then everybody's kids were
dying families were dying like man we
shouldn't drink yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um it is funny
though if you watch like clips of when
they pass drunk driving laws people are
just like are you kidding me in
my own truck the government is trying to
now they're in my F-150 what's
next you know what I mean it's like
people fight
good like any regulation tooth and nail
which like it's like the way a baby's
like I'm not going to bed suck my dick
then they you know they wake up and this
look let's say this this baby does smoke
cigarettes and has had a history of
gambling online to be able to say that
kind of stuff yeah yeah very he's got a
dirty mouth a foul mouth this baby yeah
this baby worked offshore for a couple
years here it says publish March 10th
1996 at 5: am um let me see for Year let
me see last week the Louisiana support
Supreme Court ruled that the state's
drinking age of 21 is a form of age
discrimination oh yeah and toss tossed
out the 1995 law as well as the 1986 law
that barred those under 21 from buying
alcohol Louisiana has become the only
state in the nation with a drink in age
of 18 that's not still how it is though
is it no they had to change it at some
point when the potholes were so big it
was just swallowing entire cars oh
there's people doing like spas in a
pothole where they put a um put a
heating rod down into a pothole that's
awesome pull that yeah dude they
had people yeah some people drove into a
pole dude they fil they filmed that
movie Tremors in a pole
there whole Sound Stage down there oh
there's people was in musk is doing
something down in one of them yep one of
those little tunnels um my man loves
tunnels the weather is getting cooler in
a lot of places if you go outside you
got to come back inside cuz it's cold
that's
why that means it's fine time to stock
your closet with winter
clothes with ibata you can get cash back
on winter coats hats gloves scarves and
more for the whole family that's right
you can earn cash back on hundreds of
online Brands and retailers too when you
start with ibata including Lowe's Macy's
Sephora Best Buy and more the average
ibata a user earns $100 per year that
could cover the cost of an entire
shopping trip download the ibata app
today and use code Theo to start earning
real cashback just go to the app store
or Google Play Store and download the
free ibata app and use code Theo that's
IBO TTA in the Google Play or App Store
and use code th H EO start saving
today this holiday season you might be
looking for nutritious convenient meals
to keep you energized on jam-packed days
you know it's that time of year when the
days just they go so fast and you got to
be fueled up factor is America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
they can help you fuel up fast for
breakfast lunch or dinner with Chef
prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you'll save time eat well and stay on
track with your healthy lifestyle while
tackling all your holiday
to-dos that's right Factor meals I love
them they taste good they taste like
somebody just made them in the kitchen
God they're good head to factor
meals.com
[Music]
theo5 and use code
theo5 to get 50% off that's code
tho number five number Z at Factor
meals.com
theo5 to get
50% off they are they are good they're
tasty and they got all kinds whatever
your diet is they'll do it for you what
about so the holidays what was it like
the H what's the holidays like up in
Baltimore because Baltimore and New
Orleans are pretty similar bro yeah
they're both well I I first of all new
orans rocks such a sick City but yes
they both are cities with their own like
Vibe but I don't know I mean we were my
family just did not Greek people didn't
have Thanksgiving oh really so like we
we OB we adopted that while we were
here obviously like you know you're here
you live in America whatever but like my
family was not a turkey family my dad we
would always get a leg of lamb we would
always have lamb and we would go our
Thanksgiving was we would always go to
my brother's Godmother's house who lived
just in the hood truly like she I don't
know what the happened she's the
only she's like a four six woman both
dimensions just a nice
you know where's a 38 38
pants absolutely dude all shoulder she's
the she rules yeah she's so she's like
very you want to talk about a low Center
gravity you cannot move this woman
believe me she digs her heels in she and
she just like lived in the like
East Baltimore in the 90s it was
brutal and like to that was the first
time I was ever scared of a neighbor cuz
it's a little kid you don't know any
better it's not like by the way
Greektown was not good but we were would
go there and would be like what the
is going on here like you know kids just
playing like basketball with like like
legitimately not ball like what with
like a uh yeah there'd be kids playing
with like a big
orange and they draw the lines on a
marker very large orange you know they
peel that you lose you have to peel it
for the winner and serve it to
him if you lose you get scurvy you don't
have you don't have the correct vitamin
C it was the the only orange that you
know live in a food desert of course in
the hood so it's the only orange for
Miles so that's a coveted coveted thing
but yeah they would and it wasn't
literally it was like you know um like
not a real hoop it's like one of those
crates that you cut out and I was just
like what the f like and we we were not
it was the first time I was like what
the going on here and like why
did she live here because I always
thought she was rich like in my head I
don't know she just carried herself like
a you know rich woman I guess and we
would just go there and just like you
know have watch the parade have a bunch
of weird half Greek half American dishes
she made some weird mushroom rice and
just her sons would us up you know
like that rough housing of just like if
you're if you're four and some wom's got
teenage Sons they are just you know
tossing you around slapping the out
of you being like you're a if you
tell and you're like I'm not a
yeah you're not a but you're in a
neck break and then you punch him in the
dick that's the one move like a little
kid has when when they're fighting like
a teen is just the the nice punch
oh yeah but that was our holidays were
real you know and then Christmas was
just did they have Santa would you ever
do a Greek Santa not a Greek yeah Greek
Santa tell me what you want har you know
over here oh beautiful girl come here s
s Greek Santa's like the 16-year-old
hostess at the diner is like you tell me
I tell you what you want no problem come
here I have I have for you you not tell
my wife Miss CLA don't need to
know yeah yeah Greek said all the kids
get a handful of feta from his pockets
it's like Rich inside not to deep do not
rich deep everybody have to have
feta yeah but we waited we waited in
line to see Santa Claus yeah oh
I loved all that I loved all that
Whimsical American cuz that's the
other thing Greek people do Christmas is
actually not a big deal New Year's is
when you give give presents but my they
tried that we were like look
you move to America I'm
getting my ony I'm getting my
on December 25 maybe even the 24th but
yeah we were just yeah I I'm trying to
think of what they had in our town if we
would go see a Santa you have a little
hoot NY they had a dude yeah they used
to have this place it was like uh
secondary bread or something you ever
seen one of them shops where it's like
you go get the bread but they should
have sold it yes the other day sure yeah
yeah yeah soup
kitchens like your mom's like we're
going to a store
Theo it's all bread in
there but they have a dude over there he
would pull up this kind of cage and
Santa bro and he'd be like what do you
want there Bo you know yeah come on on
th On th we going to get your
boy yeah Cajun Santa you want you want a
list like he he gave out the lamee
like he gives out lips he's like you
have ailments from C Santa you got a
cliff lip now boy you going to wake up
without your front tooth you want a
little cleff pallet from Santa huh yeah
your left leg is going to be two inches
longer than your right leg from my let
me see if I got a little polio in my
sack for you there
boy let me get something that slow you
down in the
swamp the Friendship of an alligator
he's just he gives you mystical
presents there will be one Gator he'll
be your friend but there'll be three
Gator be your
enemy he would be like let me hold your
hand and we together we'll pray for your
dead twin that was never born I'm like
dead twin his eyes roll back in his head
he's like tell Mommy it's Todd's gonna
get her
next oh that's twoo more Fant Ria for
one day for Fanta oh I need
Gumball quick get him some so he can
tell the
future oh man H get that boy craw dead
somebody get the let him suck on the
head somebody let him suck on the head
so keep his yeah keep power keep his
energer y yeah that's his present too
it's like craw dad he didn't suck on to
completion I left a little head on the
meat little meat on the head there for
you boy you been a good boy I got your
hot warm o out of my
pocket let me give you a warm oyst and a
couple Nan
tablets welcome to New Orleans
baby this here little Wayne's a box of
shorts from when he was in the hot boys
yeah yeah we got a picture of Lil
Wayne's box of short
fire police investigating viral photo
taken at mall Louisiana Santa cash and
gun let's see what happened here there
they go that's sick oh yeah
there's some dude oh that's a great pick
and what the article says there brother
I hope the police are searching them to
give them the key to the city Baton
Rouge photo showing two men posing with
stacks of cash and a handgun alongside
of M
Santa that's a sick look dude
and look at say he's dab he's doing a
dab dude that's awesome he's one he's a
couple dances behind that's I'm trying
to catch on to Black Culture yeah dude
dab came after the dogey bro get it
together one of the one of the men seen
in the photo is 29y old Almanzo Paul
almano is such a sick name oh it is just
not nope no not
Alonzo Almanzo throwing an extra m in
Alonzo it's a power move
almano dude yeah I love it yeah was
arrested Thursday on an unrelated warn
out of Texas wow so snitching they for
having some Christmas cheer it's
illegal to have a nice time with Santa
Claus now I think it's the 9mm that got
him I thought this I thought this was
America that could be a Glock yeah time
one of the most American Christmas
pictures I've ever seen what are you
supposed to do not go shopping he's got
money it's Santa's at a mall he's
putting money back into the
economy true and he's protecting himself
with his second amendment rights now did
he get that strictly legally who's to
say oh now we care about red
government red
tape yeah how do we know we in a
lifeguard bro
bro and we need more black lifeguards we
need more black lifeguards and those
pools get testy yeah let's say this we
need more black lifeguards look at me
Biden somebody Joe here's how you're
going to win here's how you're going to
win the next year more black
lifeguards uh what did I see this
morning oh Joe talking to some kid they
have some another thing with a kid up
there they I feel I'm at the point with
Biden just they it's not it feels like
they shouldn't do this to an old person
oh dude it's fully elder abuse that's
what I feel like yes yes and it feels
like it's almost like they're trying to
create Stockholm syndrome within us that
we think it's crazy like like if that
were my dad or grandpa I would be like
hey don't do this to him yeah look how
sad he
looks holy he looks so sad
dude the other day one that first of all
that looks like a guy wearing a Joe body
mask somebody get that his
dosage of super Aderall what the
dude they do I do not want to see
him in public unless they've got him
dosed with like whatever you
know growth hormone whatever dude he is
how good how good do you whatever he's
they give him must feel awesome ERS or
peptides you think whatever it is dude
some kind of we don't even know
about but yeah the other day he answer
there was some question you see that
video he answered Clarissa Explains It
All was his answer holy that was
when I was a child
that's awesome dude that's 20 years ago
but yeah he just smelled a kid this
morning and they he's like how old are
you there's a new video and he he's like
are you 17 and her brother goes she's
six sorry old habits die hard he's just
clicking he's got the kind of dementia
where he's like now he's acting like he
did in his 40s and that was when he's
riding that Amtrak down to Delaware cute
woman sits next to him on the on the
uh heading honey yeah yeah
you're 17 right yeah yeah he knows the
age of consent of all the states the
Amtrak passes goes New York Jersey eat
town oh your six your birthday is SE
September 10th hey stop the train right
here conductor stop it for 12 minutes
hey let's slow down in Delaware you know
I'm trying to meet a
girl he knows the safe havens the
16-year-old say AG oh you know he was up
hey hey right hey let me know before we
reach the
bomic
you know I gotta I got a telegram a girl
charge res B and ask six-year-old girl
if she's 17 dude is this what does this
guy want to be a comedian it's funny
though to call him creepy it's like all
right guys he's clearly losing his mind
that's what I don't like let's get you
know I don't have I have the faculties
to be a pedophile anymore right that's
the unfair part of it yeah it's like
yeah cut down in his prime now that he's
finally now that he's finally got all
the power in the world he's two SE now
to be a pedophile
it's heartbreaking of those pedophiles
dude it's like the uh the um uh
what's the the old the old sci-fi
uh oh why not you're talking about uh
Twilight Zone Black Mirror Twilight Z
yes Twilight Zone where the guy has all
the time in the world and his glasses
break and he can't read anymore he's
like but there was time now that's Biden
now he's like but I'm the president now
I could go to Epstein's Island it's like
no it's over sorry Joey it's the are
shut down
yeah just a scile Joe Biden sadly
walking through an empty epsteins Island
he like what now that I get in it's
done that was the ticket booth
right there he's just seeing a plaque
with just like Bill Clinton
smiling
yeah that's why I want a stuffed four
14-year-old that's what I want to
goldfish that's what we called him he
was a Chinese
boy if you do the if you do the
ski
ball they have that those disc toss but
it's on a Chinese boy's penis you got to
get it
on high
difficulty let's just say high
difficulty wow you're like man there's
no way to get this on there huh you're
like complaining saw Bill Gates do it he
did he had a whole I saw Stephen
Hawking build a robot that could do
it yeah they're like Dice Clay landed a
smoke ring on
it Trump claimed it was fixed yeah like
I do
it dude I saw a pothole the other day we
went to University of Tennessee football
game and we saw a pothole with just like
smoke coming out of it and it reminded
me of Trump's hair dude yeah hell yeah
that hot smoke
absolutely he's had some funny clips
recently too yeah it's interesting he
feels like he's getting a little scile
too which I'm not against right because
it's gonna get funnyer oh I think it'll
really get funny if he gets in I
think I don't know I just I I am so sick
that we're stuck in this two- parties
they it's we are trapped in the two-
party system you're trapped forever it's
obvious that we're trapped I think
humans are starting to realiz like
there's no more you can't do it anymore
people it's at some point we're going to
have to break out you you'd hope so I
don't know I mean it's true that it's
like these op none of these options are
good where it's like you see um like on
polling like the little stuff that I pay
attention to it's like when you ask
people generic Democrat versus Trump
generic Democrat wins and you ask them
generic Republican versus Biden generic
Republican wins it's like they just
don't want these guys nobody wants these
guys and it's like Democrats have nobody
they have no like KLA harff has no s
whatever they're not even making a plan
though that's what that's the part I
don't understand like what could their
strategy be they can't have Joe Biden
run again I don't think it's because
it's just not going to be to me it just
gets to the point where it's like that's
the part that's to me makes me sad it's
like can we stop doing this to this guy
like it's just not fair let him eat some
ice cream right bring in bring somebody
else in instead right now that at least
is a somebody who's viable right and for
all intents and purposes we should
consider him dead like he's not he is
technically breathing but like for all
intents and purposes the guy's got to
you know like let him retire let
him hang out retire dude he's had a
whole nice career of being a you
know one of the most lucky guys of all
time but I don't know dude but his son
died you know yeah his son died in a um
he was in a union fire or he was doing
something he was in the merchant marines
he was on the top of kilamanjaro and his
son passed away fell into a black school
district and died at the hands of uh
Naran and local believe it was either
that or brain cancer I can't tell I
would think it was that though he he
might have be I think he drowned at the
uton
zoo somewhere outside of
Cincinnati when Joe burrow threw him to
a pass over the middle yeah to dry Al
Wilson hit
him yeah to see that man God I remember
like it was yester year I remember like
it was tomorrow
yeah but everything's kind of becoming a
little bit of like a farce like um oh
did you see uh and thanks so much for
being here man this is like the funnest
conversation I've had in a long time and
congrats dude your episode was like one
of my most watched ones I mean it was so
fun people thanks man yeah no
this is so sick I'm I'm thanks for
letting me promote the special
go watch that uh uh fat
Rascal out I think now or next week or
whenever whenever this comes out but
yeah do you feel a respons ability to
stay thick kind of um yeah you know what
I do every time like a famously fat
person loses weight it does feel like a
betrayal I will admit that uh but I
think I could lose 100 pounds and still
be generally thick you know what I mean
so it's like I just want to I want to
trim it down a little bit I want to get
a little I want to get it uh you know
going a little bit but yeah I can never
be a skinny guy like you see like Fat
Joe lit the man's name is Fat Joe he's
Zed up right now oh yeah he is
his humongous head skinny as you can't
be skinny man you can't take the OIC
that far get it adjust your dose have a
little Fu have some chichiron and
stay you know big arms little
titties that's my dream just I just want
little titties I don't want them to go
away yeah oh
yeah no I would like little arms big
titties on a G oh you know what not even
little arms big arms little titties is a
move though on a woman yeah yeah
I've seen some hot big armed little
titti ladies big armed little titty baby
that's somebody raised in a m on a
mountain yes yes B yeah climbing up
somebody got to go uphill pull
themselves up a lot absolutely thick
very very like the the tips of their
finger Al basically Alban soup
fingers Albanian soup
stirs thick Knuckles you know what I
mean maybe bales of hay that type that
that style of although I have not
I haven't Tangled with too many country
girls I'm open to it but it's just never
you know I'm not around them I guess I'd
love a southern act I'd love to hear a
Southern accent while you know busting
would be cool I'm sure you've done your
F yeah oh my God oh my Dar my my God
roll somebody said one of my friends
said that he a girl from the
south and she said she was fixing to
come oh yeah that sounds I would love to
hear that fing to come fixing to come
I would be like that's awesome take your
time CU what it would do yeah what it
would do for me was I would hear fixing
to come and I would both get the rush of
a woman saying she's about to come but
just that phrase would make me in my
head smell biscuits and think about
biscuits and think about other like
Southern traditions and I think it would
be a very powerful fix I'll have I'll
have a couple of Scoops at to
come if you're fixing it if you're
fixing to come well I've never had to
come yeah put some cheese on it baby
I'll have a little of it yeah not much
you know yeah all we ate a little bit
ago well have you ever been fat at all
in your life I had a couple months where
I was fat something happened I don't
remember and uh oh I got in a wheelchair
o for what I got in a wheelchair
dude I got my penix taken out I was
running the bases I was doing baseball
oh my burst or whatever as a child
oh my God and our coach right it was
like just some God he was just so fat he
just hated gay people right that can
happen he
like your your brain gets so fat it cuts
off the empathy part of your brain so
anybody different than you you want to
just you know you want to kill
them absolutely yeah and he would like
try to point to a base and he couldn't
even he was always he has to do a
full body
point he was like a duck he was like
John McCain duck hunting you know he
just he just couldn't make my
day John M try to F just do it at uh
four degrees or under yeah yeah having
to do like glute Bridges to raise the
gun so that was crazy dude I think uh so
your popped in the fact I'm shut
down between uh second and third right
oh my God and he's screaming at me to go
and like cannot even I'm going to die
move I am going to die I'm like crawling
towards third base and our field was
kind of down Hill it all went into the
right field so I'm crawling um so I'm
crawling the uphill way yeah a slight
angle up oh half of our hits went to
right field and uh cuz it was a pretty
hard gradient out
there and so I'm going uphill dude it
was like EO gima you yeah and I've got
yeah we got like sepsis or something and
they took me to the hospital and uh so
then I was in a wheelchair for a while
and I put some of the medications they
made maybe putting a little bit of
weight so I had a lot of water retention
sure little puffy yeah and I think I
thought I was going to die so I just
wanted to eat as much as I could little
pie on the way out oh at that age C
cobbler oh yeah we didn't have
croissants in our area I don't think no
not even with the French uh Cajun kind
of beignet nothing sausage we had a lot
of roadside sausage oh what's the
strangest
sausage you have armadillo sausage no
I've had what's something that I've had
that's pretty wild I've had Dove you
know I've seen a couple Brothers damn
couple Brothers Grill up a dove outside
of our apartment complex how do you know
it was a dove huh how do you know it was
a dove they said hey homie you want some
dove you want some dove and I turned
them down most of the time finally I had
a little absolutely it's not bad but you
have to talked to them for a while right
but they're nice but they're good guys
they're just too old to be talking to a
child especially if for eating a damn
Church me like course of course what do
you think they do you think they wait in
trees above
weddings they them and they just
you just see some fat black guy jump out
of the tree we got him have you seen
that Dove they throw at that wet at the
funeral no oh yeah and it gets got by a
hawk or whatever no the one that just uh
I that's a funny one where they do that
thing where it's like well release his
soul literally a haulk comes and
takes and just kills the Dove and
everyone's
like was like our grandfather's
going to
hell pull that up man pull up brother
Dove release
death pull it if you can man brother I
think a roadside brother
uh peace
bird deceased see what you got please
type that exact phrase in there you go
that's it right
there uh you want to put them on for a
second St yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah hey my brothers I heard David said
just the day oh if I have wings like
this D for then will I fly away and be
at
[Laughter]
rest damn boy that's dinner boy and be
at rest that's church dinner um nothing
wrong with that I would eat a I would
eat I would eat most birds I would say
panda you think you'd eat
it ah good question I mean they're
sedentary animals they're pretty fat
wouldn't be tough meat it would be you
think it' be marbled kind of marbled I
mean people talk about Rogan talks about
eating bear I feel like I see
clips of him talking about eating bear a
lot or he's had guests on that have
eaten Bear yeah so Panda just a Chinese
bear little Sichuan sauce on that
I mean dude put something look at that
right there you wouldn't
have a China could send you panish to
Us's envoys of friendship okay dude pan
sear I would take that I would take a
big bear can you search can you eat
Panda yeah yeah because I've seen a
picture of a bear steak that's got me
thinking I might bear it' be
so how how how does giant panda meat
taste terrible apparently in 1983 a
Chinese villager and you knew they'll
eat
anything named Ling zong tried for
illegally killing a giant Pandy he told
the judge that his wife cooked the meat
with turnips but they didn't enjoy it so
he fed some to his pigs and gave the
remainder to his sister damn just a
couple the sister catching Strays who
was Albanian
probably damn yeah I tried to feed it to
my pigs but they were too sophisticated
so I gave it to my fat
sister hey
Marjorie got something for you this fall
you can start speaking a new language
with Babel why Babel because it works
instead of paying hundreds of dollars
for a private tour or fooling yourself
with language apps that are little more
than games Babel's quick 10-minute
lessons are designed by over
130 language experts to help you start
speaking a new language in as little as
three weeks Babel is designed by real
people for real conversations all of
Babel's tips and tools for learning a
new language are approachable accessible
rooted in real life situations and
delivered with conversation-based
teaching here's a special limited time
deal for our listeners to get you
started right now get
55% off your Babel subscription that's
right but that's only for our listeners
at Babel
babbel.com
Theo get 55% off at babel.com
Theo that's
babbel
/th EO what better gift to give yourself
or someone else than the opportunity to
speak a new language that is wonderful
have you been in an accident have you
been damaged up check your body is
something broken is something missing
that's the you're like whoa Jeepers no
wonder I'm late to work I don't have a
limb well Morgan and Morgan is American
America's largest injury law firm with
over $15 billion recovered for clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair
compensation submitting a claim to
Morgan and Morgan is as easy as as as
washing your thighs baby with warm water
and good soap Free Soap Morgan and
Morgan their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com thisp weekend or dial
pound law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's fthe
people.com slis past weekend or dial
pound law pound 529 from your cell this
is a paid
advertisement this episode has brought
to you by
betterhelp if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched up with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time which is
something that I that I recommend if if
if you aren't sure if a therapist is
perfect for you then try a new one you
know I spent a long time going to
therapist that I didn't really think
were perfect but I was afraid to speak
up so uh with better help you can easily
switch as you need to and you can always
come back to one that you've already
worked with so don't feel ashamed give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com Theo find your bright spot this
season with better help dude did you see
these two did you see this is how just
weird the world is getting Stu is like
did you see the two there was I think
Mullins was the guy's name in the
um the
senator what was this this was yeah I
think this is
yesterday or two days ago Republican
senator Mark Wayne Mullen challenged
Teamsters president Shawn O'Brien to
fight during a senate hearing rising
from a seat before the committee chair
stepped in to diffuse a confrontation
this is pretty interesting the senator
challenge him to a fight yeah it's just
crazy that like this is where we're at I
know
dude yeah let's play it now let's talk
about Mr O'Brien himself his behavior as
everybody knows in this here in the last
time him and I kind of had a back and
forth but after you left here you got
pretty excited about the keyboard in
fact
you tweeted at me one two
34 oh come five times and let me read
what the last one said um it said quit
the tough guy act in these Senate
hearings you know where to find me any
place anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place no it's not you're in the
Senate here okay that's fine perfect do
it now I'd love to do it right
now stand up but oh hold stop it your
solution every no no sit down down you
know you're a United States Senator okay
get his ass Bernie can I respond hold it
hold it get his ass Bernie this is a
hearing God knows the American people
have enough contempt for congress let's
not make it
work I don't like you cuz you just
described yourself hold it the mic you
have time your statement then let's do
this because I did challenge you and I
accepted your
challenge and you went quiet no I didn't
go quiet I was I you challenged me to a
cage match acting like a 12-year-old
School excuse me hold it no excuse me I
have M I will say I will say exactly
Senator mull I have the mic you have
questions on any economic issues
anything go for it we're not here to
talk about physical abuse that's good
man that's crazy meanwhile that
guy has two U valde mom sitting behind
him like so sad about what happened to
their kids and that's what they're doing
dude that's insane the talking about be
you're made no you're made
yeah and he's three and0 Mark Wayne what
he figh in huh probably I would guess
AAR oh yeah MMA he play yeah unitar you
think he had the under giant with the
one yeah with the one shoulder he's out
of Westville Oklahoma wow so he was
maybe Semi-Pro interesting um did he
have a nickname though that would be his
does it have
it the senator what if his nickname was
the Senator Mark govern I like that big
government Markin you have two names you
oh he beat Clinton bonds oh Clinton
bonds he beat him twice he fought Bobby
Kelly he fought Bobby dude stop
hitting me dude what the
he
lur that's awesome but it's just that's
weird man where it's getting now
that that's how we're going to raise
money for the for the for their County
or whatever for their do they're going
to do a fight versus an only fans model
and that's where the funding is it's
like the government is dead man it's
like it's I know it just feels like it's
the tech is the government now yeah it's
everything is so privatized which is an
issue I mean like I'm not I don't think
government is good but I just think you
can't trust business the thing it's like
like I don't I don't trust the
government but I trust them slight we
have slightly more direct control over
the government than we do just rich
people that could do whatever the
they want and that's what's scary is
like Tech like you're saying by default
kind of controls our lives and it's like
you know it starts out fine but like
we're just talking about it's like we've
made our living honestly a big part on
with tech companies goo YouTube's
Google they're one of the
biggest tech companies in the
world Instagram meta whatever you want
to say
and now everything's fine but it's like
these can decide tomorrow
that they can just you know what I
mean voice we don't need it it's not
part of a bigger if there's a said like
if those companies get together what
what's our goals for the next five years
okay we got to weed some of these people
out you know it's like um but you're
right in that like but you're and it's
scary in that like yeah there's no
people didn't ever respect the
government right I mean or you know they
did there was it was a position of power
whatever but it's like that's what
happens when you don't get money when
it's so clear that these
are bought and paid for that you don't
respect them anymore and so then it
becomes not who do I trust to like take
care of my district but who's cool and
it becomes a weird popularity
contest and you get a guy who'll
probably be like I'm not a I
challenge some dork to a fight
and then some morons will be
like that's my guy or like
what's her face jacking off that guy at
Beetlejuice like that was the coolest
thing she's ever done oh Lauren bber she
jacked she over the pants jacked her
date first date I don't agree with her
politics but I do agree with her stance
as a date yeah that's that's her date
etiquette is awesome yeah especially in
a movie theater and it was a packed
movie theater yeah yeah I remember
seeing that I was like wow there's other
people right there and it's like it's
the Trump effect of like yeah the guy's
entertaining yeah the guy's
entertaining well at this point that's
what I think some people are saying this
government is a it's it's I think we've
entered kind of like a private ized
communism that's what it feels like
right and I don't know if communism is
the right word but it's like a
privatized like yeah our leaders like
Tech is the new fossil fuel I used to
say that years ago it's like that's the
leaders now it's like whoever like yeah
we can be shut down in a heartbeat
because somebody doesn't like our voice
or somebody doesn't like what we say or
our direction or whatever it is and so
those are the leaders those are the
Masters and you kind of need a
government but it's like now the
government's just being used as this
shell company to kind of like that
everybody's masquerading behind you know
and also to funnel our funds into
whatever they want totally I mean yeah
it's like I wouldn't say communism I
would say like it's kind of like a
oligarchy which is like the
little the few control everything which
is like they're not redistributing
yeah like that's the other
thing dude is like we don't even want
that much like at this point I'm just
like dude you want to you want your
pedophile like Tim Dylan has that point
where it's like just go you know go on
your
do whatever but it's like could we have
some healthare like could we have could
we have the bear like before have a neck
brace so at least when the PED at least
when the pedophile story breaks I can
sit up and look at my television yeah
yeah yeah you know but it's that's the
thing is like it's not like 40 years ago
the rich didn't have better lives than
all of us and the government didn't use
their you know Senators didn't you know
the kennedies were using State Police to
FY 18-year-olds from Boston in and out
of them bring them beer and like the
powerful have always whatever you want
to say like they are going to have more
privileges than us and that's something
we can work on longterm to get rid of
but like now it's like they are sucking
people dry completely and it's like all
the everyone every like all these cators
are like insider trading inequality is
so crazy where it's like normal
people cannot pay their bills at
all and it's like and and then you have
like scapegoat issues the The Playbook
is always like let's turn people against
each other whether that's like you know
biger like you know blacks and whites
black Trans all this yeah it's
like that's that's always the Playbook
where it's like that doesn't
really if everybody had their F if
everybody just had health care they had
a job that paid well they didn't have to
worry about like you know if an
emergency happens am I going to
be out on the street oh yeah people had
blood pressure medicine they wouldn't
say the N word I think absolutely know
what I'm saying absolutely dude but
sometimes your blood pressure so high
you got you get over you get over 180
dude you got to drop at least a soft day
I mean you got to you got to let
some steam off the top that they
prescribe that you go to certain you go
to certain first date or uh emergency
room they give you a bag and nobody can
hear it just shade into this please and
a muffler a silencer it's the it's like
it's a megaphone but it's like like a
like a gun silencer you're like go ahead
sir shout it into that and it just comes
out so
quiet
beep and it actually registers like a it
also a dog hears
it yeah it tells your blood pressure at
the same time
yeah so if you do hit a certain blood
pressure like well it's a loud or it
comes out in Morse code you say it it's
like dude yeah there was some story
about a guy who was like Mor like who
was uh doing Braille the nword all over
the place and people were
reading
it I think that was in outside of
Philadelphia oh man that is I got to
admit that pretty
good I don't like nword vandalism but
it's a it's a pretty if you're blind you
only see black anyway so just to be able
to pull it up with the Run of a
finger here there has got to be it has
to make you giggle and I think blind
people deserve Laugh To Laugh that's a
good point blind people deserve to laugh
more than anyone that's a that's a very
good point and if if putting a couple
end
bumps on Chipotle tables is going to do
it if caring a couple hand bumps at a TJ
Max and that's our
healthare that's the closest we're
getting to healthare yeah I know dude
it's it's tough not to be
like like almost like nihilistic where
the shit's just not going to get better
where you're like it just feels like
they're G to they're going to suck
people drive so much and I just don't
see any representation of like what a
lot of I mean it would have to be like a
a youth movement I think but right of of
like young people just having enough of
the and like cuz old people just
going to stay conservative that's how it
goes traditionally and I just think like
I don't know man you just got to
has to get shaken up and we just need
just basic I mean you saw obviously
I was a big Bernie guy and you there was
a big outpouring of like like Trump and
Bernie it's not a it's not a coincidence
that two kind of outside different
things really registered with people at
that time ran together yeah yeah I
really do because I think then you have
where the two if one of them gets provid
one them gets president they have to
compete they have to work really work
together instead of just working with
some guy you picked you have to work
with the other side gu I know what you
mean but there's no way like those guys
were so aart on so much but I know
what you mean like but but as a as a as
a person an American would been in like
oh that this is what I need there I
think that actually would have resonated
with people just because it's like you
know they were saying some Sim I mean
obviously their Solutions were very
different but like and but like they
were saying similar stuff about like
this is just not you know I don't
know that Trump was talking about
inequality obviously but like they just
felt like Outsiders in a way Trump was
saying more General stuff Bernie's
message was I think way more like you
know economically focused and
redistributive but like yeah everyone
just wanted something new at that time
and we didn't get it and we've doubled
down on like and then ultimately I think
Trump got into office and it was like a
pretty run-ofthe-mill he didn't really
do anything crazy you know anything like
he didn't really shake up too much
and then you get Biden who's the most
like you know it's it's it's been the
same again over and over again
right that's what everybody's realizing
I think it's kind of no matter where it
goes and that's what thing it's like uh
I think that's where people are at it's
like is this salvageable or is America
just this experiment of Freedom that
didn't pan out right yeah know what I'm
saying like yeah is are we realizing
that this is how capitalism Falls
because a lot of it is really greed I
think there should be a cap on how much
money you can make as a
dude I fully agree I think like when you
look at how many what like big projects
happened in America like when we got out
of the depression all this stuff it's
like after a certain amount of money you
got taxed at 90% And it's like I know
that sounds crazy but it's like when you
have when you're making a hundred
million dollars a year do you really
need 110 you know what I mean like is
that that 10 million makes such a
difference to other people and it's like
nobody's saying you can't be prosper you
can't make a ton of money and you can't
do any of that but it's like just
also let's take care of the
people that you know because that money
comes from somewhere that's what pissed
me off it's like Amazon made so much
money during the pandemic and it's like
they don't pay tax people's money dude
that was like people were yeah exactly
they businesses figure out a way to like
not never pay any taxes and you
have to be so rich to figure that
out and it's like you know the people
that get squeezed the most are in the
middle it's class classic stuff it's
people who work hard as but don't
you know you make like you have a family
your taxes are crazy you're a
small business owner your taxes are
crazy but if you make $40
million somehow you don't pay any taxes
you know what I mean it's there's a lot
of ways for people to hide stuff it's
definitely tricky um you know yeah and
then and then the lie that oh that our
tax money that it's not like the foreign
aid thing I think at a certain point
it's like oh totally how you can
walk out of your house and want to
contribute to America any like you can
only burn people so much before they
like you know what man you win fine
right I don't mean anything right right
no I agree and it's you can only do that
so much to so many generations and then
people see it happen to their parents
they see it you know and it's like we
never protected Americans information
like that's another thing it's like
people's information just became
backhanded deals and and
everybody everybody's mother's getting
scammed or losing and that it's
like we don't even your phone number is
even protected I get numbers from some
dude some guy some uh Argentinian guy
all the time telling me to vote
for him I don't live in his
country I don't live in his country and
I can't understand half of what he's
saying but this sounds hot
yeah some some South of the Border it's
just basic stuff man so yeah no I agree
and it's your the information thing is
really interesting too because it's like
talking about how big Tech like kind of
controls everything it's like
why don't those pay us for
our information they have just taken
people basically they're using us as
free lab rats for all their it's
like why doesn't Google just pay
everybody $4,000 a month yeah why not
they're making way more than that off
every human being why the
can't they provide like pay us for the
work we're doing for you and
it's like no one and it's like yeah look
I'm at the point where you're going to
steal my information but instead of just
like you know instead of instead of just
like opting in and that's that it's like
well pay me for it right you
know what I mean it's like you know like
pay us if this is our if this is our
world and you're using us to
test all your and you're using us
to do all the pay people for that
and it's like you know I don't know
I maybe Universal basic income is so
it's kind of that's something that's
kind of interesting it's like if AI gets
really crazy it's like well let's let's
have people have like a basis have all
their bases covered and then hey if they
want with that basic income to just hang
out all day
be kind of poor but have their you know
have all their needs met and just paint
and draw and do whatever the you
want it's just up that like AI
now now they're like how is how did
computers become the thing and
machines became the thing that does art
and humans are the ones in
Amazon warehouses like shouldn't
shouldn't the robots be working so we
could paint why the how the
are why the do you type like uh uh
Superman with tits and blond blond hair
into a computer and the computer does it
and then it's like but some guy's
putting a 16 hour shift for no
money why aren't why aren't the robots
the slaves how are humans the
slaves and we like that should
we should have lives of leisure with the
AI it should be the coolest thing of all
time but that's not how it happens we
get some Albanian robots we need to get
some that don't know yeah exact you want
them to be Albanian because they're not
going to get smart like Skynet they know
their
place well you see that chat GPT it just
uh they just fired or the CEO they they
did this whole Facebook backhanded thing
where some of them voted like the Sam
Alman guy got voted out by his Partners
oh okay it was like some Yiddish melee
and they
all in the middle of the night they all
voted each other out of the
and
uh interesting yeah I don't I don't
follow that too too CL chat GPT
too too too closely but yeah that
was like the first one Chad maker Chad
DBT maker open AI fire founder Sam mman
um pushed its co-founder and CEO Sam
Alman pushed out its co-founder and CEO
Sam Alman after a review found he was
not consistently candid in his
Communications with the board of
directors what was he lying about I
wonder I don't know they don't get into
that it doesn't seem like um all that
yeah who knows is a hit 20 who co- found
it open about a years ago with a handful
of others and the idea was to create a
nonprofit huh yeah you know while chat
gbt became one of the most viral Tech
products in
scroll um oh this is this is a
transcript of a podcast oh it is never
mind yes it's too much but they voted
him out a girl came in and now there's
pull up a picture of these guys of the
chat
gbt group Founders yeah yeah let's see I
bet they're hot as nuh dude he's
not that bad he's not as bad looking as
no no he's handsome guy Sam is pretty
handsome guy look at uh but there's
there's a group of four of them if you
can see more his eyes though I don't
trust his eyes they're sad in a in a way
that looks like he wants revenge yeah
he's not doing oh there they are right
there oh man my man's mid-air transplant
oh zoom in on them what the is
going on there zoom in on those
dudes scoot
over so Sam mman is the guy in the back
right they in the middle of the night
the guy in uh
uh they voted him out I believe and the
guy in the
middle uh the other guy was like only
one bald guys is allowed only one guy
with up hair and then the guy the
guy who ended up them all
somehow I think is the guy on the bottom
right damn I mean if you're hairlines
like that you're a you're a
menace you want you want the world you
want to take back what the world took
from you which is that weird little that
weird little fuzz top he's got oh yeah
dude who's the who's the P I don't know
she is is pretty though she's dressed
like Elizabeth Holmes which you wouldn't
want to do if you're a tech person right
remember that oh yeah the blood girl hey
this Blood yeah put this blood put your
blood in this xrox
machine and it'll literally print out
what your what your blood type is like
literally people were dripping their
blood into a glass xerox machine putting
the lid down and it would print out if
you needed vitamin D or not that's how
stupid people are like this dude
needs hat GPT dude
he really I'm g go ahead and say that
what's that dude's name go all
these creeps Amen brother because at a
certain point people are just ruining
Society yeah at a certain point why
isn't there a
politician that's like hey this this
that we're doing is ruining like
our America why don't we get to vote
like hey this shit's ruining Society
yeah we don't even feel like a person
anymore you feel like a victim to your
phone you don't there feel like there's
no use to you anymore like you're
literally killing the spirits of people
over time right I totally agree I just
and it's like and not to sound like a
downer I love life I'm grateful to be
alive absolutely but I just feel like
there's more to our lives and it can be
a richer experience if we don't let it
get sucked away by just by by technology
I don't know how you do it but I bet
people would vote to say yeah I kind of
agree with you I think they would in the
abstract but in because I'm with you
fully right I this discussion with my
friends all the time CU I have friends
who make good points they're like
they're like I mean they're like look
this is just how Society is constantly
technology is at least In Our
Lifetime right like since the Industrial
Revolution it's like every 30
years gets crazy right like and I
don't think it's natural obviously but
it's like a lot of the we do is not
natural right we're podcasting
right now you know what I mean like they
didn't have this man was not meant to
podcast you know what I mean but and so
on on one hand I'm like well look
technology is always going to expand
people are always going to like relate
in different ways but I do think that we
are getting to a point where it's like
this is getting so unnatural where it's
like I think we and the only solution
though is to take a really to take a
really active like step and say I'm off
my phone this amount of time or regulate
your phone use or like because people
agree with with us I think but then
they're like they're not going to stop
how can we do it you know what I mean
it's like you it's almost like we are
it's like waking up and realizing I
got to go to rehab but it's like the
entire world is needs to go to
rehab exactly it's like it's like runs
on these systems and it doesn't it
doesn't feel like it's going to go away
at any point and I think the
only it's almost like a privileged thing
like look me and you could go
take a take a two months in a cabin and
not be on our phones we'd be okay we can
hire you know like I literally
hire somebody a post on Instagram for me
cuz I don't want to be on it right yeah
cuz like I I would go crazy if I
was but like a lot of people don't just
like we've backed people into a corner
where it's like so much of Life happens
online that it's like what the are
they really going to do you know what I
mean I wish it would be you know one of
my favorite times as a child like our
family wasn't real close and one of my
favorite times was uh like sometimes the
power would go out yeah dud get the
candles out get the CES out and we'd all
to get together in the same room and we
hated
but for that 4 to 40 hours cuz we're in
the poor area you get power last
absolutely I mean we would go to school
still hadn't had power other people had
power there were rich kids like showing
up with like just pictures of power that
they drawn at their house yeah they have
a little electricity oh extra static
shocking you yeah like we got extra
a lunch box it's just a couple
watts in it they're eating yeah they're
eating light yeah yeah you see you go
down there throat their stomach
glows I bet you wish this was powering
your grandma's pacemaker huh
but so but that was like the kind
of the nicest time in a way because you
needed each other it was like I needed
if I wanted to walk to the other part of
the house I needed my brother to go with
you I needed there was just so much
connection and I wonder if like you
could just say hey on Sunday I think
yeah it's off yeah absolutely shut it
down I mean but that's the thing it's
never gonna be worldwide it's something
people have to do for themselves it's
something people have to just take an
active role in their personal lives and
and it's swimming Upstream from society
which is like use your phone do all this
pay with a QR code all this
it's it's crazy and I'm with like I
when I'm done the tour and I'm done I'm
doing a bunch of podcast I'm trying to
promote the special um but I'm taking a
couple months off and just not doing
standup at all just not doing just
like truly chilling I'm getting a
flip phone dude dude I'm going
flip mode and I'm just I did that a
couple years ago for two weeks and it
was like I just cleared my head in a
crazy way where it was like no phones
before I had I would literally check my
phone for like one hour and I would just
like and I would not check it for like a
couple hours until I woke up I would
read a book that's what I would be
because your brain's like let me check
my let me check my you know
what I mean like you're just wired that
way your brain's totally absolutely it's
the it really is trying to bet betay you
your brain is trying to get you
dude it's like who's who's paying
attention to me you know what I mean
well that's a scary part too about the
ego you know like uh having an ego is so
scary because that thing's growing while
you're not even noticing you that thing
is planning it's plotting against you in
a weird way it helps you in the
beginning but then it kind of plots
against you oh and that's a that's an a
whole other like you know can of
worms right like that's a whole other
thing you have to take care of but it's
hard and it's a different a different
problem but yeah dude reading a
book and like not and going for a walk
and like just truly but dude the amount
of effort that took I planned it I told
people I was like I will not be
available constantly text this
number you don't know because it's my
burner that's the only way to
get a hold of me only contact me if
something is serious and it's
like you have to almost like plan for it
when it's you can't just slip into
being a regular human being you
know yeah it takes him it takes an
effort it's true and you have to want it
and part of you can can easily be like
you know what I don't want it I just
want to stay here and be a be be stuck
in this hamster wheel Joey paliano in
The Matrix you want to eat the
steak dude you know what I mean that
what he did was it Italian he's yeah
yeah remember Joey P uh he's the guy who
betrays them oh there's Italians it's in
the AI yeah oh God yeah you should have
known it's in the code that's you know
not there's a bunch of Italians in the
code I got it now you're definitely out
I just I don't know like I think people
are I don't know I don't I just I'm
going to need to get a little bit more
land to separate myself I
think a moat you going to get a moat I
got close neighbors dude you get a mo
with like uh black teens playing
innocently that would keep Italians away
black teens playing innocent yeah yeah
yeah just riding their bikes you know
not up to anything illegal but Italians
would see that be like I got to get away
from here like so hey this
neighborhood's not what it used to it's
just like black kids drawing with chalk
having a nice Sunday they're like Jesus
Christ what happened here we
used to beat each other over gambling
deaths at this Playground now these
kids are playing checkers yeah
now we got a couple black Taylor Swift
fans out
here that's when you know the world's
getting crazy those black Taylor Swift
fans dude I know I know we just had they
just had a blackface occurrence where
was it can you bring that up brother wow
somebody else tried it they tried it
past Halloween yeah oh yeah a November
black face is a very interesting move
yeah this is kind of the off seon I feel
like absolutely dude come on a middle
schooler who went to a football game at
my former high school has been suspended
for wearing black face I was in
attendance to this game which took place
on October 13th a student attends M
mands which is right next to the high
school um can we see a video or picture
let me see oh oh there he is right there
I mean is that blackface though or is
that just emulated the style of eye
black worn by many a
yeah yeah the dude I think is just a
black he's just a shitty painter
that's crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah either
he's a bad yeah he or a bad racist also
yeah he could just be yeah he's
definitely a shitty painter but it's
like did he mean to do blackface or did
he mean to do I black we don't know he's
that bad at painting the guy is yeah
yeah I mean that's crazy dude I think
yeah and he didn't even do his forehead
I think you could call him
mixed you know you could say the works
it's not it's not percentages you could
say the guy did the guys out here Ben
Simmons or he's naturally pretty Ben
Simmons though yeah he's he's kind of he
looks kind of Ben he kind of looks like
Ben young Ben Simons yeah def look so
that I think is fair you can't say this
dude is fully black face black I think
at this point in society you should be
able to do half blackace half oh you
think you should do a nice mocha well
people are mixed yeah yeah yeah yeah
what if you're a honey badger fan well I
still I don't think you should do I
don't think you need to paint your skin
his skin color to show that you're a fan
of maybe just his jersey would be fine
yeah you could do just a jersey but I
think if you really want to freaking get
in
there okay get in the game wasn't that
somebody's M for a while game get the
game it's in the game okay okay this is
interesting if you want to do blackface
you have to prove that you are a
hardcore fan of the black person that
you're doing the blackf face of okay you
know so that's fair you know you can't
be doing there has to be a true has to
be a true homage I want I want to you
have to pass like a driving test but
it's like what college did Tero go to
how many interceptions did he have in
2012 you know what I mean and if you Ace
that then you get then you get to go to
uh you get to go to uh Sephora
matches get a foundation that matches
his skin completely and then you
got they should have that Sephora
section Sephora Sephora for the modern
racist look they're not all cold black
there's
yeah let's be let's be realistic let's
be realistic they just cuz we're racist
doesn't mean we can't have some Artistic
integrity it's funny too because I think
some guys would no one's lips are that
red get get the real lip colors I think
some guys wouldn't some people wouldn't
care it's I think we're probably one
generation away from probably people
being able to dress like their favorite
if there's an athlete that's black I
think we're also probably two
generations away from everybody being
mixed you know yeah I think so I think
we're getting there what else I
personally don't want I would love to
have uh like everyone in my family's
white yeah get you something huh let's
mix it up a little bit oh yeah you know
I don't want now look I fall in love
with a white woman I fall in love with a
white woman what are you gonna do but
why not get a little something going
also adoption I feel like more people
should adopt if only because why do you
want your genes out there I'm a
idiot my family's dumb as we should
end this like let's an adopted kid is
like take a lottery ticket dude
it's a scratch off yeah some of them
will some of them will kill you when
you're sleep if they're from if they're
from
Russia yeah well that's what scratch off
sometimes you get but sometimes
it's like uh oh Asian girl that didn't
want this to affect her going to grad
school you know what I mean like but
then you scratch your arm like oh meth
had you tried to sell the
baby like damn this is tough I knew
I shouldn't have bought that from that
gas
station the pump said out of service I
should have known I had a friend who did
have a Russian or maybe he was like
Lithuanian adopted brother didn't kill
anybody but had a hammer on him wow
really and it really affected my friend
he was like this is my brother but man
his because he doesn't have he's not
saddled with our little dick jeans he
has those big hu you know nice
fat Lithuanian je yeah for a dick
to make it all the way across the ocean
he wrote on it it was buoyant enough to
support him that thing's got to be yeah
that's like the life of pie you got to
be able to travel yeah yeah it's the
tiger it's attacking people in the boat
uh What uh what other news did we get
man what else
happened b l us stuns Young Americans oh
yeah this was on Tik Tok oh wait first
on Tik Tok can you see the blackface
charcoal guy can we look that
up just YouTube Just
more black face there must have been
some blackace in
uh does
blackace uh head in bag do that
blackface charcoal guy head in bag cool
[Laughter]
guy as long as you don't talk in a
different voice yeah I think you're good
with the charcoal mask yeah you can't do
a voice you can't there it is right
there guy puts a bag with a
barbecue charcoal on his head let's see
if this is black face or not
interesting and this is in Russia oh
[Music]
Russia oh yeah yes this guy's a GU
[Laughter]
fan oh damn know that's an even coat God
damn wow why did he do that huh because
it doesn't feel like he's being racist
it feels like he's being weird and
Russian yes see that's interesting that
is interesting if he'd have put on a
James Harden
Jersey right and kept switching teams
yeah something tells me he wouldn't pass
our test he would know hard what year
which Year's Harden won
MVP shout out to harden by the way
really I love it dude did you see that
thing that the guy did the other day
yeah he got he went off on it but here
here's what I'll say that guy that is
the most I've ever connected to an
athlete because it's like yeah
working hard dude go get fat as and
still get what you want that's awesome
he's not gonna win a championship Jordan
I've I cannot relate to Michael Jordan
at all be being obsessed with your
job like a nerd wanting
to be the best in the world not having a
relationship with your kids all your
Harden is living life dude and if you're
thinking about the kind of guy you want
and he gets he's always won every thing
he's gotten to play with all his friends
like when he moved to the Nets and it
was like I just want to hang out with KD
again that's the most like yeah dude
you're you're past your Prime you won
your M VPS they did video games a lot of
herd yeah dude they were they they got
drafted they were in OKC together and
they was like it we're going back
there and then they played with Russ
again and it was like I relate to get
being in your 30s and just want to hang
out with your boys when you were 20 yeah
like he like that's a great
Point man that's a great point stav cuz
we all we judge these athletes on like
they have to be these serial
killers that care about anything but
championships like no Harden has made
300 million $400 million
would he win is he going to win a
championship probably not he's got two
MVP I think two MVPs and yes he falls
apart in the playoffs but okay he's
still better than 99% of human beings
that have ever played basketball and he
made $400 million he never had to work
that hard he quit yeah oh he did he
didn't show up in the playoffs yeah dude
you know what happens when it's
Thanksgiving week I don't answer
emails I'm like James Harden I don't go
my boss calls me at 11:00 p.m. it's
going on mute I'm not answering I'm oh
the office is on fire I don't give a
I'm off the clock brother yeah yeah
this is overtime I'm here but I'm not
gonna work
hard that's why he's getting fat he's
spending all his money getting I
love it dude bro that is excellent man
you're right dude James Harden you're
doing it he's the man he's American he's
a that's the most American of all
time like all right if I try really
really hard I still might not win a
championship so why not not try that
hard at all and still have a sick life
yes that's why I with Shaq too Shaq
dude Shaq could have been could
have went won way more championships but
he got you see him when he he at LSU
he's like a skinny guy oh yeah and then
he's just like I'm just going to keep
getting fat as yeah might as well
I'm going to do Shazam in the off season
I'm going to do I'm going to rap I'm
going to get fat I'm going to
buy Burger Kings and like that that
and even today to this day shaqs on TV
Dude talking about
basketball clearly does not watch the
games yeah just like has no idea
what's going on yeah Icy
Hot the insurance he's just constantly
doing commercials dude he'll yeah he'll
sell something dangerous and then the
insurance right after like get the new
Shack archery
kit right right you got a neighbor
that's out of
line he'll just grab a ball off a rim
not anymore right nothing Shack arrows
Shacks arrows yeah hey and then the next
CER is like oh is somebody shooting at
your
house get the insurance it's perfect
yeah you need the guardian or whatever
it is that little insurance guy
oh yes the general yeah put Icy Hot on
your
grandmother and get the
general but yeah no it's I respect
athletes that are just like this this is
my job it rules I'm going to have the
best time in the world and I'm
not going to be Jordan dude look at the
Last Dance Jordan is sad his
eyes are yellow yellower than
that 24 right there you know what I mean
like he's drunk as this like he put
everything in those years and yeah he
was the man right and of course I
Michael Jordan's the man I
respect him but it's like you'd rather
be a guy who's a choke artist in the
playoffs but made millions of
dollars and by the way Harden had some
good games against the the Celtics last
when he was on the Sixers last he had he
had a couple bangers but still you'd
rather just I would rather just be a guy
who's awesome as and never wins but
has no stress versus a guy who's like
lives and dies with you hear Larry Bird
talk about championships he's like it
doesn't feel it just doesn't feel
disappointing when you win and when you
lose you want to kill your it's like
that crazy and like his and it's like
that's a serious killer and yeah
he's awesome but I don't want that
dude I want to have a good ass time it's
a great it's a great it's a great Point
man I think it's just an overall good
point about how like we get caught up in
having to be the champion yeah and how
unrealistic it is that everybody's going
to be the champion toally totally and to
recognize do I really want to do all
it's going to do to possibly be the
champion and then what are you
realistically left with like yes there's
some recognition to it but is that worth
the things you might sacrifice along the
way you know yeah totally and yeah and
just because something your job doesn't
mean to be the champion long as you show
up do a good job and have fun have fun
entertain people you know what I mean
awesome that's great man I really
appreciate you thinking about that yeah
yeah yeah of course dude yeah it's it's
just it's true it's like because you get
on this invis it's almost like instead
of walking when you get to the airport
sometimes and miniapolis which by the
way they've done a great job great
airport great airport um you get there
and you can go on that track or you can
just walk you know what I'm talking
about with the moving floor yes of
course and you just like you just get on
that moving floor and you just you're
not even really thinking about your
steps no you're just you know but it
does feel cool I will say it is sorry to
muddy up the analogy no it's but I feel
fast as when I like you go on those
and you I even pick up the pace and I'm
like I'm Superman I'm bionic you
go fast you walk on them oh wow love
that feel you feel so fast yeah oh you
feel like you're in a threesome I feel
like
no that for me historically that's uh
nervous blowing it you know having the
worst time in my life uh I've had I've
had I've had a nice one but most of them
been brutal what city you have a nice
one in Chicago okay and one in New York
but yeah had some bad ones a couple
other places oh you've been in a multi
multitude of them been in a couple yeah
my I I ended my special with a I did we
talk about this last time it feels like
we did remember cuz I feel like you were
in one I was in a unique when out
outside of Missouri time yes we talked
about it we talked about it grateful
everybody made it out
okay to be honest you know it's just
yeah but if you're crushing it if you're
crushing it in threesome that's probably
what that feels like well my thing was I
didn't know one of the girls so I like
was trying to small talk while I was
hooking up with this other girl so it's
like it was like hey where are you from
you know oh you have family and you're
just make it just the whole thing was
just ridiculous what other news we got
let's bring a little bit more up I think
you just got to turn I think you just
got to turn that brain off brother when
you're when the dick is hard the brain
is off that's that's I think how it
needs to be oh my that has been my
number one problem I remember when I
used to be able to smoke weed sometimes
my erection cuz my brain would shut off
yes and my erection dude it would be
like oh my God it would be like somebody
that had gotten to the to the top of a
hill for the first time in its life oh
my good this this view is unbelievable
stayed up there was doing
selfies yeah dude I'm with you too that
is always my problem cuz I when I
actually like a girl the first time I
her I have been hard 0% of the time
because I'm worried I'm going to blow it
but then if I don't get if it's like you
know just we both know the score we're
just here to bust no problems dick wise
and then again if I break through and
I've been dating somebody for a while
and I trust you know all that all the
like anxiety of like does this person
like me all this when that truly
goes away not just intellectually but I
feel it's going away my dick actually
truly gets hard really and then we broke
literally this happened to me where I
dated somebody and we finally I felt
like we finally got all our figured
out and my dick was getting harder than
ever to the point where she was like
what's up with your dick like she was
literally like something's different
your dick is like actually she was
like she was like mildly uncomfortable
the first for the first time ever having
sex with me she was like your dick is
has gotten not small anymore like that
was essentially not big not big but not
small you know and then literally we
broke up it felt good it felt good
feeling positive yeah yeah man yeah
that's I I I've I never try and work
through that uncomfortable phase to see
if there's a real phase on the other
side it's so hard for me man I it's
scary I for me too that's the only girl
I've ever done it with and I will tell
you this it took a while to like get
over that but once it happened it felt
awesome and like I've been too busy the
last couple years like I don't feel like
a I don't know if you feel this way but
it's like on the road constantly and
shooting a special and working on other
projects I don't even feel like a person
like I barely see my friends I barely
see my family you can't have a dating
life because you're just not in a
City for longer than whatever
and so I'm really looking forward to try
to like focusing on that in the
next year I'm taking most of the next
year off wow really yeah yeah I can't I
can't be a yeah I can't like from St
from the road anyway like I'll do local
I'll work on my Act
and I'm going to say you know you lose a
lot of money doing that but it's like
what do you have the money for yeah um
but yeah dude I would say give it a whir
it's worth it because I felt it w and
you know it ended up we weren't right
for each other for other reasons but you
know when you get when your dick gets
hard from love that's special oh wow you
know that's a special thing yeah I want
that I think I think you can have it
you're a wonderful guy a a girl would be
lucky to have your truly hard dick
uh anxiety free
oh can't even imagine that really I know
it is hard to imagine when it happened
to me I was so I was like what's going
on here no way yeah I can't imagine like
getting like having a natural like just
being yeah
rehard I'm reh
harded I'm a
rehard yeah
dude the way you know your love when you
like a
reard
yeah I do not I am like a sniper I
literally have to get my wiener hard run
in there I'm like go go go you're
getting the signal I'm like a Navy SEAL
dude shout out my friend Lance but I had
to get out I would have to get erected
run in there do the damage and then slip
out yeah yeah yeah I mean before the
gates even closed I'd have to make it
back
out I get that man oh man um what's else
what else what other news we
got
talk no oh yeah this dude this this is
just exactly where we are again as a
society George George Santos they said
he spent 400,000 on only fans again of
his campaign fun I got to say respect
this guy's a idiot and he's like
like that's the thing this guy's a crook
right yeah and he he re
realistically like was like well a way
to be a CR a sick way to be a crook is
to be a or representative and he's just
killing it dude yeah this
happened more and more he spent a
honeymoon in
Vegas um he did a Hampton holidays being
a chubby guy with botox is awesome
Hampton in huh that's not very expensive
no no the Hampton's in uh Long
Island oh that dude I like Hampton
they redid them about 12 years ago the
Hampton ends they're great in guy I love
them elevators are all the same they
have like a little nice positive thing
on it with like a black kid on a rope
swing or like a white kid like getting a
lemonade from his grandma yes yes yes I
was always a holiday and express man
when it came to the lower levels I I
haven't been to I not a Hampton in guy
my top spender she put up well here's
his problem he also put George Santos as
his screen name wait what the
that's a girl right that was her but her
top spender she's saying she's an only
fans model but he's gay Santos is gay is
he yeah well he spent
$435,000 attempting to not be gay what
the go to this girl's is that a is
she trans or something or is she does
she Peg guys yeah let's see if she's
transed up or maybe she guys no
wow I mean if she's trans I'm sucking
that thing no problem if she's trans
dude uh Red Rover Red Rover I'll be
right uh oh I might have to I'll be
right over
wow what's her name I mean she seems
like she has she might be trans which
again no problems here so ass sex huh
what we scroll down just a little bit
and George Santos was looking at her I
thought that guy was gay as hell yeah he
might not be gay anymore I think for
$435,000 you can make it out of
anything you know yeah that's true where
I'm from anyway that's a nice no that's
a nice chunk yeah you know that's a nice
chunk absolutely you can stuff the
condoms full of money and just to keep
your dick hard that way in a
woman worst case scenario doesn't Santos
also have like a hot also scammer sister
I think I saw somebody tweet about that
well a lot of people are just making it
to Pol it's politics now but it's like
they're well it's it's funny because you
don't want lifelong politicians it feels
like because the system is so dirty of
course but then it's also like you you
get these like just fly by night kind of
people like fetman
right um who I'm not saying is bad or
good but he's just you know so as he
shows up like he's you know like it's a
off day whatever yeah he's got his
uh sweat shorts on me and him
dress way too similar oh that's a good
point although he's not this dripped out
but you know on my on my on my travel
days no if you're dripping he's he he's
a leak yeah it's like he wears like
Champion Athletics yes yes yes you know
which a lot I respect it it's
comfortable
um he paid her rent that's his sister oh
George hendo's sister Tiffany hasn't
paid rent since 20 2020 respect another
scammer in the family yeah so it's just
that's a lot of what's going on um yeah
absolutely what else what was that other
story you had
up oh this was interesting Bin Laden's
letter to us stuns Young
Americans he was
right a decades old document allegedly
written by Osama Bin Laden entitled
letter to America recently went viral on
Tik Tok with some Young Americans
believing that the al-Qaeda founder made
valid points about their own country I
mean I don't know this letter but
American imperialism definitely led to
terrorism there's no way around
I mean that's the thing no innocent
people shouldn't have died no
terrorism's up in any way but
it's like you can't say that America
didn't act up doesn't to this day
act up in foreign countries and
yeah we've been destabilizing the Middle
East for you know what I mean like go
back to that article if you don't mind
please brother I just want to see a
little bit more uh keep going
down it's wild and everyone should read
it said one Tik Tok user warning that
the letter had left her very
disillusioned and Confused um Bin Laden
the son of a wealthy Saudi businessman
founded alqaeda or the base in 1988
following the Soviet defeat and
withdrawal from Afghanistan a conflict
in which he fought I didn't know he was
a fighter oh we we we supplied
them cuz they were fighting the Soviets
a lot of like supplied them yeah we
supplied a proxy war yeah absolutely ah
under his leadership the group launched
several deadly attacks and bombings in
various Nations including the attacks on
September 11th
2001 um the Bas is an interesting name
for a terrorist group yeah it's the bass
you think they were
teror
teror and they do that cool yodelling
the creation and continuation of
Israel is one of the greatest crimes and
you are the leaders of its criminals Bin
Laden wrote each and every person whose
hands have become polluted and the
contribution towards the crime must pay
its price and pay for uh heavily oh here
it says the Saudi born militant then
wrote the Palestinians had to be
revenged along with the people of
Afghanistan so what he's saying is oh
and here it is the American people are
the ones who pay the taxes which fund
the planes that bomb Us in Afghanistan
the tanks that strike and destroy our
homes in Palestine the armies which
occupy our lands in the Arabian Gulf and
The Fleets which ensure the blockade of
Iraq this is why the American people
cannot be innocent of all the crimes
committed by the Americans and Jews
against us all right we had to we had to
hit it hit us with a jade didn't you
Osama but so what is he saying here he's
saying I mean he's basically saying that
we have a we we can't you can't just
look at America's actions as no
repercussions of them I think so I mean
look obviously OS I'm not Osama Bin
Laden's off here right like obviously
I'm not aligned with Osama where he's
basically like neither one of us are
he's basically like yeah yeah I know I'm
sorry I don't mean to be like I don't
mean to be like you no no but I think um
he's Bas I think he's saying that like
by just living in America no one's
innocent and you're able to
that's why I think that's how they're
talking about terrorism and stuff like
that um and and but I do think what he's
saying obviously he's wrong about that
right we you shouldn't kill
innocent people at all but I think he's
saying that American imperialism is like
people are going to be pissed
off about that and yes America has
supplied Israel with tons of billions of
dollars and that and they they're they
need Israel America needs Israel because
it's a
strategic you know base if in the Middle
East it's the only it's the only like
Ally that they have there you know and
so um and they've they've just kind of
turn we've all kind of turned a blind
eye
to God the situation in Gaza where it's
like yeah unfortunate they're completely
they don't have an independent
government they're under the rule of
Israel and each year it gets like a
little they take more and more of their
like you know the land whatever and and
I guess the whole point is like yeah
America has been acting in a lot of
up ways that A lot of
people are pissed off about I think a
lot of people don't know about either
probably totally absolutely absolutely
like you don't think sometimes that like
if you go and do something in a country
if your forces it's like you want to
cheer your forces on cuz they're your
team right they're the people that are
keeping your country free but if if you
kill people in Iraq because you're
hunting Al-Qaeda totally and you kill a
ton of civilians totally the children of
those civilians and the brothers and
fathers of those civilians are going to
want to uh
lived if like if you were under if
you're in Iraq if you're in Afghanistan
post war if you're in uh you know Gaza
under occupation if you you see you see
your loved ones get killed by a
different a foreign country a foreign
country's Army and you're not it's like
the Cat Williams joke where it's like
what does the Iraq army uniform look
like you know like I don't I'll wait
like we've never seen it he's like we're
just killing we calling
them insurgents dude cat has the best
that's the best
that on the Pimp Chronicles it's the
best Michaelson joke and it's the best
Iraq war joke I think um but anyway
that's the thing it's like yeah people
are going to be pissed off about
that yeah that's the same thing I think
that it's like you know people you see
like the the you always hear like the
free Palestine movement you know and uh
for me it's like if a place you when you
hear the free thing like free that place
usually needs help right yeah that's
place that needs it's like yeah you
don't hear fre America you don't hear
free Israel you don't hear free China
yeah you don't hear free South Carolina
you yeah you don't hear free Nevada you
know you
hear you hear free Palestine they it
just man it just shit's heartbreaking
over there without question yeah and our
news doesn't even cover it fairly either
no it it's ABS not at all I mean no one
is for terrorist and it's like the when
you when you point out that the people
in Gaza have been under you know
military occupation with like not you
know not access to water like they have
like a ton of a ton of crazy and
not even we're not even getting into um
you know what's happened now which is
like they're killing so many civilians
it's out of control it's insane
and it's like to like the the response
is I mean it's like a it's like a moral
crime what's happening and but we've
ignored the context of that situation
which is like yeah dude these like think
exactly what you said it's like think
about what would happen if Americans
were put under that you know that's the
whole point right of like I mean
especially if you're like a second like
the guys who always talk about I have a
gun in case the government were to
like that's happening to those
people right they're they have no right
like they're they're they're like it's
crazy the situation over there and right
now it's like hospitals are getting
bombed it's like yeah and if your if
your army is so like such a talented
Army as Israel has right why don't they
send guys people in especially if you
already control the area you're telling
me you can't s like I would rather have
our Navy Seals go in yeah absolutely and
do the job in an effective manner
efficient I know there's no way that's
the thing against you know against the
terrorist people right right right the
people who did it BL it just
seems like the not only cruel but the
dumbest thing well it's like
especially for people that have lived
through Iraq like we live through that
we our gener like we this country
did there was obviously protest but we
basically were like all right we're
taking you okay I guess and then it's
like it was complete they were
no they had no
yeah yeah saddam's saddam's
sons were too busy buying like
golden whips to hit their
slaves with they were they were
buying tigers and to eat Kurds they
they were like they yes they were
horrible people but didn't have
nukes this is his son right here he's a
goth son he's actually going to be in
he's and he's with a he's with it looks
like an older woman which is kind of hot
wow it looks just like his father yeah
dude that is funny to to be goth
AMA yeah dude it's like uh what's a good
goth man that starts with L um Lamb Of
Gods Not
goth uh or or like heavy metal yeah yeah
I don't know I'm I'm I'm thinking of a
lot of M's Mega Death
Metallica uh gez I'm really blowing it I
was just trying to think of a good play
on words sorry man I'm I'm out we both
check swinging we're like H we'll take
another pitch we're gonna we're gonna
pass on that riff I wonder if it'd be
interesting to talk with that guy oh are
you kidding me it would be
fascinating I bet that would be
fascinating I mean wow I would love to
talk with that guy and just see what he
cuz he's just a son you know
I can't even imagine what his life is I
mean he had a ton of kids Bin Laden they
were so I mean they're rich as and
you know I believe culturally it's like
you just have a ton of kids if
you have that much I mean his painting
suck dick but that's like I would buy
that probably that's not bad I guess if
your nephew did it but also
you're learning to paint in a cave dude
I think he's in
America we don't know if he
is I don't know bro who knows painting
by lamp light yeah dudee if
you're painting by by lighter although
didn't they F when they found when Seal
Team got him he was in like a mcmansion
in Pakistan wasn't he where was he at um
you know there's a lot of rumor that the
guy who said that they say shot him
didn't shoot him oh you still out there
or they were just oh no no he's deceased
gotcha cuz didn't they throw his the guy
that did it or claims to have done it I
I've just heard that there rumors that
that's not this right oh yeah because
there was like one guy who's on podcast
all the time yeah Michael uh
I O'Brien I think is his name it does
feel like I read the book The book's
amazing okay his book and uh he's a NE
guy I've met him but people say that who
knows yeah but I think there's this or
maybe there's just a thing it also could
be you're not oh Robert O'Neal that
you're not supposed to say what happened
if you did it yeah I think that's the
code of conduct apparently it feels a
little like you know it's like you know
act like you've been there before like
don't do don't do a dance like a wide
receiver hand hand the ball to the ref
go kill the next terrorist you
know what I mean like there's a lot of
yeah rumor like that um which I get but
yeah that stuff's heartbreaking I I want
to have some people on that know more
about maybe that kind of Stu I'm too
stupid I I mean you know but yes
absolutely I mean it is it feels it
feels like you have to like it feels
like you have to do something cuz if
you're the power too of course you were
the one that has to figure it out this
the other entity that's not as powerful
or doesn't have any powers or only has
limited powers is they can't it's not
there's no way for them to figure it
like yeah I mean and and the yeah you
definitely should have somebody on who
knows more like about it but it's like
the history is crazy because it's like
yeah not only do they have it's like
they the people there have they've tried
for two-state Solutions in the past but
nobody wants to talk about how like
Israel didn't want that anyone who was
trying to have a peaceful thing like
they assassinated a lot of peaceful
leaders and they there's even like they
helped fund Hamas because they wanted I
believe they wanted the PLO again don't
but like it's just it's just the kind of
thing where this this thing is so it's
so up what's been going on for 50
plus years in Gaza and it's like I don't
it's not that I don't understand why
Israel is a you know I understand why
Jews are a little on edge I get it like
there's there's so much
anti-Semitism in the world but it's like
that does not you think there is in the
world yeah I do think there's generally
anti-jewish sentiments but I also think
oh yeah yeah there probably is but but I
also think like that doesn't we're not
talking about Jewish people we're
talking about the state we're talking
about a state government we're talking
is we're talking about a yeah exactly
government and it's like that's those
aren't the same thing and a government
that no has people that are extremists
in it is different than you know well
that Netanyahu guy seems he just seems I
I I he gives me the creeps yeah they
have I mean they have people in the
government that are just like we should
exterminate them like they're just
straight up saying crazy racist and
it's like that has to also people also
need to know that dude like it's
not it it's especially if you were a
group that somebody has already said
that to but maybe that's like the thing
where if like somebody says something to
somebody like hate create hate you know
I don't know I don't know how that stuff
gets stuck in people's DNA and stuff
like that you know I know but yeah just
um I don't know this is
heartbreaking it's completely and
now there's too much visibility now
where we are in like with social media
everything for people not to see what's
going on I do think and I also think
there's like a a generation of people
that like for younger people it's like
they're just seeing what's going on
right now you know what I mean they're
just like this is up like you can
have any you know any um you can have
the reasons you're doing this but like
we're we're 19 we're living through this
moment right now and we're we can't
believe what the and they don't look at
the history of stuff because they don't
really have a long history in their
lives yet so they don't really history
is not a part of things to it's like
what's happening right now how does it
look right now that's the way Society is
now how does this look right now but
it's also I do think obviously you
should know proper context and you
should do your research but I also do
think there is something to that idea of
like it's also free of a lot of thinking
where it's like oh yeah we're just we're
just taking these at face value like
we're just seeing this and this is not
acceptable to us but who knows we
obviously I'm not I'm not the guest for
I'm not the guest for super in-depth
like that but what's you're like a
yeah you're like a gorgona judge yeah
dude bring in some aged
cheeses bring in a rib bring in
a ribeye I'll tell you which one's good
four ribe eyes I'll slurp a bowl of bre
down what are we having for dinner by
the way um what are we going to get in
between before the show man hilarious
that's what we got to be talk that's
what we got to be thinking about you
right listen let's keep potting but in
the back of your head you think about
the dinner brother
yeah what could I go for a Porter House
doesn't sound too bad good boy don't
sound too bad to me
brother Cordell Stewart blew a guy at
Shenley park over there the fruit
loop Pittburgh is unreal
huh yeah I mean that whole the it's that
white trash is everywhere that's
Baltimore talks like that Baltimore does
too Baltimore Philly it's a little
different t t oh my God what the hell
are you talking about you here's what I
say about Israel pal on let him fight it
out Arabs versus Jews who gives a
that's what those guys think put it over
there Joe make it a Raven
Country put a stat take a put a statue
of Joe flacko up
there we will Annex Israel for
Baltimore start serving crab cakes out
of that mother Ray Lewis was a Jew yeah
they'll start saying all kinds of
oh yeah mhm Matt Stover he was Jewish we
should get the country that should be
for the Ravens
mhm I know I feel bad for my Jewish
friends too that are like why are
we
getting if they're getting Flack from
people because they're country because
they're
like or because they're the yeah well
you should absolutely it's ridiculous to
blame Jewish people right like it's not
and that's why it's like I don't want
but that but that's like you know you
don't want anti-Semitism to get worse
because of this obviously like like you
don't want this like really we need you
got to stop bombing the place
immediately like you got to have a
ceasefire it's crazy not to do
that and then it's like let's can we
actually try and have real
productive like peace talks like could
could something good happen out of this
I don't know I'm little and why can't we
step in and try to help we're the ones
that are America is part of the group
that and Britain that helped create it
right yeah it was briti it was it was a
British colony before and then they were
like all right we feel bad about you
just take this essentially you can't ref
the first quarter and then
all right boys call your own
fouls
yeah but one team owns all the balls
yeah one team's got all the
whistles that's perfect dude that's why
you're great man cuz whistles was the
right joke it's all right man that's all
right wh was the right
joke stavi anything else you want to
think about man I think we've talked a
lot huh yeah I'm good bro I mean we
could go this is the easiest podcast in
the world we I could we could do this
for 10 hours we got a show
tonight I'm trying to think if there was
anything else that we wanted to learn we
got the special is out people can watch
it it comes out December 5th December
5th on Netflix I'll make sure to post on
my socials too on that day man I'm sure
people are going to be excited to see it
I just watched Trevor Wallace's new
special I thought it was really cool I
haven't seen where where's it on it's on
uh I want to say Amazon maybe oh or Hulu
but it was just cool Trevor's a hard
worker man that kid yeah yeah yeah he's
a great dude and I love just his whole
thing is like so ridiculous um they did
did they do a podcast where it's like
just to talk to porn stars because I
really respect that I think they have
them on sometimes they're still they're
still jerking off a
lot I respect that from a philosophical
standpoint it's like like you know who's
the king of that is that guy Glenny oh
Glenny balls yeah I mean I got I got to
meet that guy cuz I feel like that's a
path my life could have gone down he
just has a show with the express purpose
of trying to porn stars yeah he's
the man respect I'll of a uh Buffalo
cheddar before uh before you come yeah I
have that yeah that's the best part it's
like I've seen a couple Clips he is not
good at
interviewing yeah yeah and like these
girls also are not like the most
talented orators so it's like not
compelling content it exists solely for
Glenny balls to get his dick sucked and
honestly
salute yeah dude welcome to America
Glenny just like James Harden respect
yeah you're the James Harden just having
a good time dude oh Glen's hilarious
dude Glenny is the most lovable there is
if you see him he's literally like every
he's like a French Bulldog but that had
a lot of quasons you know definitely
yeah a fluffy old French Bulldog oh he's
got some there's some flake coming off
you know I respect yeah like I just I
don't know I don't know the guy
personally yeah he's great but but no
the show is he's like yeah you like
having uh tits in your
bra yeah oh man I'd love to know his his
conversion rate on the podcast he says
all the time yeah I don't try to have
sex with these girls like well if you
don't Glenny then what are you doing
then you're an Albanian journalist you
try to get on 60 Minutes you think this
is step
one bro then you're just an
Albanian yeah ex that is ALB that is
Albanian TV is like we find the biggest
breast in village and we ask question
and we see with camera on breast whole
time I did go to my Albanian friend's
house one time as a child and they had
just gotten Albanian TV oh it's
beautiful and they had it was like a
variety show where it was like
skits and it's obviously all this
comedy's you know back 80 years there
where it's like all the skits are like
men dressed as women you know what I
mean like just like that level uh
and then the DJ in between skits was
someone called DJ topless and it was
straight up you're not GNA believe it's
Theo a woman with her tits out on TV on
like what's on like on a Sunday
afternoon this woman just had her tits
out spinning Euro trash music it was was
awesome see that's the kind of
diversity we need in this country
absolutely got titties out free free
free the nipple for sure free America
dude that's right before it's too late
before it's too late we got to figure it
out we just got to keep communicating
too and thinking as much as we can and
making people laugh man you do a great
job of that star thank you man this is a
highlight of my month man thank you dude
anytime and dude we got to get you on
stav's world sometime you're in New York
and where do you tape in New York New
York yeah I'll come do it this year hell
yeah dude I'll come do it this year man
I'll do it next um
yeah I got a couple IUS that's a tough
thing with pod it's like you get a few
IUS and then you're doing your own and
you start touring and you're like course
no I get it and maybe we can figure some
out on the road who knows but
anytime you want to come on and
dude I'll do the show every week if you
want me to no well you're always welcome
but I I owe you man so coming over there
and um yeah congratulations dude thanks
Big it's exciting to see you manage this
and just and just have an experience and
yeah that James Harden approach I like
it that's that's all that's you know
obviously my favorite player is Giannis
he's the the man and he's more
of the like I'm going to work
hard I'm going to improve and he's but
he's also got his family right like
there's different approaches to it but
like at the end of the day I just tip my
hat to a man who just says yeah
I'm not that not going to care about
being that good at my job I'm G to care
about my life being better and I'm gonna
I'm GNA be a little more hardened this
year I was a little I was a little too
much like Kobe last year you
know yeah be a little more Harden on
yourself yep I'm going to be Harden and
then I'm going to get rehe harded yeah
I'm going to find a woman and get rehe
harded we really came up with a great
loophole oh I can't wait to shut down my
central nervous system and get an
erection that's bro that should be our
national
anthem
yeah unreal absolutely yeah I'm
a I'm a Marshon bamp fan dude oh yeah
yep um awesome dude yeah uh thank you so
much stavi and uh congrats again brother
thanks dude thanks for having me all
right peace Alex log goes
congratulations to on the baby on the AL
baby the AL
babian now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel I'm falling like these
leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my life
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to take
little